dans chaque ville dans chaque village du
crâne des meues de chiens orphelins ou
abandonnés les combats ont tué ou fait
fuir leur maître ils sont restés
derrière étant de s'adapter
une situation qui désole profondément
lieu de Milla d'Anna chaque jour cette
bénévole se rend dans ce refuge pour
animaux abandonnés de crématork pour
nourrir les chiens et leur donner un peu
d'amour
j'ai pitié de dit-elle si j'avais une
grande maison je les hébergerai chez moi
ce centre accueille 56 chiens à porter
ici par leur propriétaire incapables de
les garder ou par des militaires les
ayant secourus près de la ligne de
France
des animaux sans défense souvent blessés
toujours traumatisé dit maman les
humains peuvent s'occuper d'eux-mêmes
dit-elle mais les animaux domestiques
sont perdus sans nous
mais même dans cet abri les chiens ne
sont pas en sécurité il y a quelques
semaines à peine un obus s’est abattu
ici au Canada mais il s'en est fallu de
peu
c'est que
cramatorking de kilomètres de la ligne
de France à portée donc de l'artillerie
russe le refuge fondé il y a quelques
années par Kyril hanchera était
initialement beaucoup plus modeste mais
depuis le début de la guerre il est
débordé
on doit faire des choix dit-elle on
accueille en priorité les animaux qui
ont plus besoin d'aide ceux qui ont été
blessés ou qui ont des problèmes de
santé
mais le refuge n'a pas vocation à garder
ses chiens éternellement l'objectif est
de le retrouver de nouveaux foyers
malgré la guerre malgré tout beaucoup de
gens veulent des chiens et des chats
dit-elle ceux qui reviennent à la maison
se sentent plus en sécurité avec un
chien
c'est le cas de Young Mila Danina qui a
adopté de chiots blessés du refuge il
constitue déjà le centre de son univers
en ces temps incertain rien de tel pour
se rassurer et se changer les idées que
la compagnie de ses compagnons à quatre
pattes ici Jean-François Bélanger
Radio-Canada Kramatorsk